[Musique]
une fois le pied posé sur le sol
américain julian assange devrait être
conduit devant un juge fédéral le jour
même il est plus que probable que ce
dernier prononce un placement en
détention préventive de la julian
assange sera le plus vraisemblablement
incarcéré au centre de détention pour
adultes d'alexandria en virginie
les audiences devraient se tenir au
palais de justice d'alexandria devant un
tribunal fédéral
la date du procès n'est pas encore
connue d'autant que julian assange
dispose de plusieurs recours face à la
justice américaine
même si le sixième amendement de la
constitution des états unis précise
qu'un accusé a le droit d'être jugé
promptement dans les faits les délais
peuvent être très longs chelsea manning
par exemple qui a transmis à wikileaks
des informations classées secret défense
a ainsi passé plus de trois ans en
détention préventive avant même le début
de son procès
[Musique]
julian assange est visé par 18 chefs
d'inculpation notamment pour avoir
obtenu ou divulguer des renseignements
relatifs à la défense nationale ainsi
que pour avoir conspiré en vue de
commettre une intrusion informatique
au total s'il est reconnu coupable de
toutes les charges retenues contre lui
il encourt jusqu'à cent soixante quinze
années de réclusion s'il est reconnu
coupable il est probable que julian
assange soit incarcéré dans une prison
de type super max pour super maximum
security qui devrait être celle de
florence dans le colorado une prison
surnommé en fer version high tech ou
encore l' alcatraz des rocheuses
et pour cause alcatraz est considéré
comme le prototype des prisons supermax
s'il est effectivement envoyé là-bas
assange y rejoindra le narcotrafiquant
mexicain el chapo luna bamber théodore
kaczinsky ou encore l'auteur des
attentats de boston
julian assange y sera détenue seule 22
heures à 24 heures par jour dans une
cellule de 5 mètres carrés en béton
isolé phonétiquement et dont le peu de
lumière passe par une meurtrière d'un
mètre vingt de haut et de 10 cm de large
seulement ses seuls contacts les
gardiens lui apportant serbe a à travers
une trappe lors de leur sortie les
détenus sont entravés aux mains et aux
pieds ses conditions de détention déjà
drastiques pourraient être rendues plus
sévère encore par l'instauration de
mesures administratives spéciales ou sam
en anglais destiné à protéger les
informations relatives à la sécurité
nationale
cela implique moins de visites de
courrier et des communications
téléphoniques limiter à une demi heure
par mois selon une ex cadre du système
pénitentiaire américains ont entendu au
procès en extradition de julian assange
l'esam boeuf conduire à une dépression
sévère à de l'anxiété de la paranoïa et
de la perte de poids et est généralement
préjudiciable à la santé mentale
l'état de santé de julian assange
justement est d'ores et déjà source de
préoccupation et a alimenté les débats
lors de son procès en extradition le
fondateur de wikileaks souffrirait d'une
dépression sévère serait sous traitement
médicamenteux et présenterait des
troubles de la mémoire de l'attention et
même des hallucinations
julian assange serait enfin en proie à
des pulsions suicidaires son extradition
augmenterait la probabilité d'un passage
à l'acte